This video is brought to you by Squarespace.
For decades, reusable rockets were commonplace
in science fiction.
But they only became a reality in 2015, when
SpaceX landed the first stage of its Falcon
9 for the first time.
NASA never tried to do anything like what
SpaceX is doing.
The closest NASA ever got to anything
like it was the semi-reusable Space Shuttle.
So, why doesn’t NASA fly reusable rockets?
To answer this question, we need to go back
to the 1960s when NASA designed the Saturn V
and hired contractors to build it.
This monster rocket sent astronauts to the
moon as part of the Apollo program.
Fully fueled, it weighed over six million
pounds or about the same as 400 elephants and
stood taller than the Statue of Liberty.
The Saturn V was not at all reusable.
The first two stages would fall into the ocean.
The third blasted the astronauts to the lunar
surface and would either remain in space or
crash into the moon.
I doubt it ever occurred to the people designing
the big F1 engines that you could make something
that big reusable.
And at that point in the evolution of the space
program, I don’t think reusability was a consideration.
The government agency was instead focused
on landing the first-ever crew on the moon.
A NASA employee also pointed to another reason
the Saturn V was expendable.
A flight operations directorate named Robert
Frost explained that only about a dozen launches
of the Saturn V were planned, so it was cheaper
to use a disposable launch vehicle.
In the end, the Saturn V ended up being very
expensive - costing $185 million for every launch.
That’s about $1.3 billion today adjusted
for inflation.
NASA was so burdened financially that potential
plans to produce more than the initial 15
Saturn Vs had to be scrapped.
Then and only then did the agency consider
a reusable rocket.
Senior NASA administrator George Mueller championed
the development of a fully reusable system.
But the Space Shuttle never became quite what
he envisioned.
The engineers found out that it was too expensive
and too technically challenging to make it fully reusable.
They settled on making it partially reusable.
The orbiter that housed the crew could be
re-used.
So could the two Solid Rocket Boosters.
But not the large external tank that held
the fuel for the main engines - that would burn
up in Earth’s atmosphere.
Despite its partial reusability, the Shuttle
failed to lower costs.
NASA pegged the price of a launch at $450
million. However, several independent sources
estimated that the actual cost was around
$1.3 - $1.5 billion - in the same ballpark
as the Saturn V while carrying less payload
- making it more expensive on a per-pound basis.
One reason is that the Space Shuttle required a
lot of work to prep for another mission.
For example, 21,000 thermal protection tiles needed to
be inspected.
The boosters had to be fished out of the ocean
to be refurbished.
So, it became difficult and costly to turn
around the Space Shuttle quickly.
Plus, the production facility that churned
out the external fuel tanks could only manage
a maximum of 24 a year.
The Space Shuttle would only end up flying
an annual average of 4 times annually  anyway.
Tragedies like the Challenger disaster also
halted the program for years.
NASA never achieved the rapid reusability
characteristic of private companies like SpaceX
which hopes spaceflight will one day be as
routine as plane travel.
That is a difficult feat.
It took SpaceX 13 years to successfully land
a first stage.
Unlike NASA, SpaceX started out with a vision
of building reusable rockets and stuck with it.
Others are also banking on reusability.
Blue Origin’s New Glenn will be designed
with a reusable booster.
ULA is considering catching the Vulcan Centaur’s
two engines mid-air.
China is developing the Long March 8 to land
its first stage.
Despite the technological advancements in
rocketry, NASA’s upcoming replacement for
the retired Space Shuttle is still not reusable.
The Space Launch System is intended to carry
heavy payloads to the moon and maybe one day, Mars.
The core stage is being built by Boeing but
the rocket is also using some of the same
hardware from the Space Shuttle.
And will actually discard the RS-25 engines
that the Shuttle did re-use.
So why not make the SLS reusable?
NASA says it’s to bring down costs and speed
up development time.
Because again, it’s not going to be used
very often.
Going to the additional engineering, the additional
cost of designing something that big to be
reusable compared to how infrequently it’s
going to be used, I think the cost trade-off
is in favor of expendability.
It may only take off once a year whereas the
commercial sector could be the one organizing
regular trips to space in the future.
Headlines have questioned whether the SLS
is even worth the expected $2 billion dollar
price tag per launch.
Especially since SpaceX is building the giant,
fully reusable Starship.
Musk has said that in time, each launch of
Starship will only be about $2 million - or
0.1% of the cost of the SLS though without
NASA, there would likely be no SpaceX.
The agency handed out billion-dollar launch
contracts that kept the company afloat.
Plus, the purpose of NASA is to do the research
that private companies don’t do or won’t do.
As the private space industry grows, NASA
may never feel the need to develop anything
fully reusable.
The SLS is expected to take off in late 2021
at the earliest.
My previous video compared some of the current
and future rides to space.
The video is also available to watch on my
new website, Newsthink.
I made my website using Squarespace, which
sponsors this channel.
Whether you want to show off your work, run
a business, or a blog, a website is a great
way to build your online presence.
Squarespace is very easy to use.
You don’t need any experience in website
building and there are many, beautiful templates
to choose from.
You can try it out for yourself for free for
a couple of weeks by going to squarespace.com/newsthink.
The link is in my description.
And don't forget to use my promo code NEWSTHINK for 10% off your first purchase of a website or domain.
For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.